معي هنا في استوديو مذيعه سابقه في قناه
العربيه وهي الان رئيس التحرير في قناه
الحدث سمار جابر وهذا دليل انه المذيعه
فيها هي تكون صانعه محتوى فبدي اقول انه
شكرا وشرف كتير كبير انه يكون معك اليوم
على شرف اكبر انه يكون معك واقول كل عامة
لصحافيين والصحفيات اللي بقولوا نحنا
بالشكل وانما مضمون سومار هلا هي رئيس
التحرير
سومار بالاول بدي اقول تغطيه حرب تموز
ولكن قبلها اهم شي كان اغتيال رفيق
الحريري حتى اللحظه هو اهم زعيم عربي
يختال بهذه الطريقه كنت على الهواء شو صار
وكيف دعت الخبر
كانت نشره عاديه واجا خبر انه في انفجار
ببيروت كنا عم نواكب نحنا بكل الاحوال
جلسه البرلمان اللي كان هو حاضر فيها وكان
في مشاكل اقتصاديه وسياسيه مثل ما بتعرفي
ريمو بكل الاحوال بلبنان وقت اللي قالوا
انفجار ببيروت يعني ابعد شيء عن ذهنك
ينقال انه رئيس الحكومه رئيس الحكومه مش
عم بقول لانه لبناني رفيق الحريري شخصيه
عربيه معروفه وشخصيه دوليه معروفه
عاده مثل ما انت عندك اللابتوب موجود في
انفجار بس ما حدا بيقول مين اللي استهدفوا
متل ما بتعرفي انت دايما بتسمع المخرج
واذا في شي لبروديوسر هو اللي بقول لك نحن
بدنا نحط عاجل او في هذا الخبر لحتى تكوني
واثقه انت من ذاتك وتقوليه
سمعت صوت بيقول لي الحريري
ما يعني هي قصه ما عم بقول وقت هي خمس
ثواني لن اتطلعت على اللاب توب ما في حدا
جايب سيره انه رفيقي
على
السكرين كمان ما في عاجل بس كان هذا سبا
انه بغض النظر سبا ممكن يكون خبر جميل جدا
وممكن يكون خبر محزن جدا بس سبق الصحفي
سبا صحفي ما رديته وكملتها اليوم يمكن ان
تكون شخصيه لبنانيه مستهدفه على الهواء
كان غسان مكحل بوجهله تحيه
فساعتها وقت اللي يعرفوني انه انا مزعت
الخبر لان الصوت اللي سمعته مش صوت
البروديوسر والضجه بقلب الهيدا فانا بدي
اتاكد لان هيدا منه خبر قليل
بسمع ساعتها شخص بيقول لي انا عبد الرحمن
الراشد قولي تم اغتيال رئيس الحكومه رفيق
الحريري وقت قتل
ساعتها قلت بس بدون اي شعور
وقتها تغير مجرى تاريخ بلبنان يمكن
التاريخ بلبنان وكان سلسله بمجرى التاريخ
بالعالم العربي اللي شفتني كتير يعني في
حديث كتير عن حرب تموز كمان بس بهالسيا
بدي اذكر زميله نجوى قاسم هي صديقتك وراح
يكون في اليوم لها محط بس حابه انا شخصيا
احكي معك عن نجوى اولا لو ما نجوى ما قدرت
تطلع على الجنوب كنت انا ما اخذت فرصه
المهنيه هذه الفرصه حطتني على خارطه
الاعلام لكن نجوى هي الغائب الحاضر لا
تغيب
فبدي اقول لك شو بتقولي لا لن نجوى هيك لو
كانت معنا لان كان بيلبق لها تكون معنا
بهيك النهار بيربق لا باس
روحها معنا
بيلبق لها لانه مش غايبه عنا بس كانت
مذيعه اساسيه
مش نحن عم نحكي عنه
وكانت مذيعه رئيسيه شو كان مهم انه تشوفي
مذيع رئيسه مثل نجوى قاسم نازله مراسله
ميدانيه نجوى مش مذيعه مع كل احترامي نجوى
مذيعه شيشه نجوى صحفيه صحفيه ارض ومش
صحفيه لبنانيه طيب حتى موز عم نحكي عن
نجوى كمان من المحطات الاساسيه الاساسيه
اللي غطت فيها الى اي درجه موضوع حرب تموز
ايضا
برعت في قناه العربيه لانه اخذت خط تحريري
مختلف عن باقي القنوات بس هو كان الخط
مش لان انا من العربيه ولا لاني صحفيه او
بنت العربيه بس هو الخط المختلف اللي عم
تحكي عنه اللي كان مع الشعب اللبناني
الدايركت بس كان انه هذا الحرب ليه
وهالدمر ليه والقتله
قدره العربيه تبين انه هذا الخط الصحيح
اللي هي مشيت فيه حرب تموز بالنسبه
للعربيه كان مفصل تحريري سابق مش لان انا
فيها انا بنت جنوب لبنانيه كنت عم بغطي
وعم ابكي كانوا اهلي بالجنوب بس كنت عم
داوم
13 و14 ساعه وكل بين فتره وفتره اذا لقطت
معي تليفون بدي اطمن عن اهلي بس كنت راضيه
عم ينقال لان تغطيه نهر البارد كمان تغطيه
المهمه بلبنان وطبعا لحقها كتير من
الاحداث الاساسيه انفجار مرفق بيروت صحيح
الى اي درجه بتقدري كل لبنانيه كمواطنه من
هالبلد وصحافيه تقدري تغطي احداث هالقد
مصيريه
بموضوع لبنان بموضوع لبنان بتقدري تغطي
لانك انت بنت لبنان بتعرفي الزواريب يعني
عم بحكي اليوم شوي
السياسه اللبنانيه زواريه وشوارع وطرقات
اللي ما بيعرفها بده يشوف فيها لانه هن
متوهين بس الاهم انه متل ما بتقدري تغطي
بلبنان درنا نغطي بشوارع ثانيه بدون ثانيه
وانت قادره يعني ريما غطيتي كل شي من
لبنان لبره لبنان واي صحفي عنا عمل هيك
شكرا وانا بدي استسقي كمان ساعه سيلاوي
الله يرحمه كمان اللي اخادرونا لكن بقيوا
معنا بيروحون سومار بذكر كانت مذيعه بقناه
العربيه وهي اليوم رئيس التحرير وهذا دليل
اخر على انه الناس تيجي لهون وبتبقى كل
عام وانتم بخير شكرا كثير شكرا للمشاركه
ميرسي